I mean, even though the reality is,
you know, Facebook is a technology,
I'm here that the Facebook friends
are going to really hate me for this.
But here Facebook is a technology to
exploit insecurity for the purpose of
selling ads.
That's what it does.
What it does is make you feel
like you've check and you're like,
why didn't she like that photograph
or why isn't he friended me?
And so you constantly engage because
you're constantly trying to feed this,
you know, feedback. And
that is exploiting Tristan.
Tristan Harris's work is really a powerful
here is exploiting your insecurity
and severally what it is.
Because I've always thought about it
as being a fast food version of the
nutrients that we're missing in an
actual real community. That's so good.
That's exactly the right
way to think about it.
But just in the same way that fast food
companies figure out how to exploit the
brain chemistry that makes it so
that you eat chicken wings, you know,
barbecue chicken wings because they know
that's what's going to feed that kind
of addiction. And just like
gaming companies figure
out how to tweak the game.
So that they'd know how to get
the addiction out of your kids.
This company is really great if by getting
you to like turnover as much as you
can to them to build you into this quote
community. Why are they doing that?
Not because Mark Zuckerberg has come
some kind of freaky guy who wants to know
your secrets, but because the
more you turn over to them,
the better their ads are
in feeding you information.
So this is a technology for the
purpose of engendering advertising.
And so that advertising gets really,
really good. And so, you know,
you could say that Facebook
is tilted to the left,
but the reality is there
was an extraordinary amount
of exploitation of the
advertising inside of Facebook
to feed information to the right.
And this last election, I mean this is
what Kathleen Hall Jamieson Book about.
This is really quite amazing and
documenting and that's because it's gotten
really good at being able
to segment markets on the
basis of what people know or
care about. Again, not because anybody
planned it, nobody wrote Jew hater.
But because the AI is smart
enough to figure that out.
And so when you build this technology
that is driven to the purpose of making it
easier to sell ads, you produce
this world that um, you know,
has no necessary connection to figuring
people, figuring out what the truth is.
Again,
think of cable television.
Cable television is about
building really loyal community,
building the tribal
sense of the community.
If telling the truth did that
they would tell the truth.
If not telling the truth does
that they will not tell the truth.
And the question is not whether
you're telling the truth or not.
The question is what builds the
advertising base. And so this,
this reality that we have, these
platforms that are ad driven, um,
distort or constructs drives that
platform to develop in certain ways.
And that's why I think it's
important to think, well,
what if we could create a competitive
environment where there were different
platforms available, ones that we're
not focused on, you know, driving ads.
And this is something that I get, I think
power. They fund those. Isn't that the,
the the reason why something like
Google or Facebook has gotten so big,
it's because there's so
much money behind it. Well,
two things because they've been allowed
to get so big and because so much money
behind would stop them. The
antitrust departments, you know,
the people in antitrust department
would step in and say, Facebook,
you become too successful.
The way you're buying up competitors
is disturbing to us. Well, but again,
the thing of the difference in that
sentence, you become so successful.
That's one sentence.
And what we want to do in America
encourage companies to become successful.
I believe in, you know, innovators and
markets working that's really great,
but you've bought your competitor
is a separate statement.
Like you have a bunch of money because
the stock is so valuable because people
think you're the future of money,
but then you turn and use that
money to buy a competitors.
What are you putting
up, Jamie? What is this?
That's the total number of
they've spent in the last, I,
I think it was seven years to sell the
companies they bought. Scroll back. Don't,
don't move. Okay. Total
cost of acquisitions.
What does that $23 trillion billion.
Billion.
$23 billion more than the gross
domestic product of a Fiji,
Zimbabwe and mild Deeves combined.
19 billion of that was for that one.
What's that? Really?
Yeah. 19 billion. Holy.
Anyway. Yeah. So, but the point is,
when you're talking about acquisitions,
you're not necessarily talking about
companies that are succeeding because
they're so good.
Right.